tilly cse sommier sur lequel il
travaille depuis plus de neuf mois dans
l'entreprise familiale que nicolas des
ponts veut faire connaître au prochain
concours lépine
première particularité de son invention
une adaptabilité maximum à l'utilisateur
on a développé un algorithme qui permet
en fonction de la morphologie de
l'individu d'adapter les lattes en
fonction de son poids l'ate simple
double ou combinaison des deux montées
sur des rotules pour le confort de
mouvement et la démarche se veut durable
tout est remplaçable individuellement en
cas de casse le point clé c'est
finalement changé juste les pièces
d'usure les lattes les rotules si
vraiment nécessaire et l'habillage de
manière régulée en fonction de ses
envies pour la partie couture est issu
l'innovation a été soutenu par
l'entreprise
eurosites un support essentiel pour une
petite start up une entreprise se
développe pas dans un désert donc si on
a un tissu économique au niveau local
qui est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on ce
qu'on pourrait estimer pour un
territoire comme la nièvre il n'y a pas
de développement économique parce qu'une
entreprise ne peut pas se développer
tout seul on l'a senti aussi qu'on était
poussé par
à part les grosses structures qui nous
qui nous entraînait et nous soutenait
dans notre notre projet c'est ça qui
nous a motivés aussi à continuer et pour
un produit responsable et 100% nivernais
nicolas des ponts délègue une partie de
la fabrication bois un établissement
dead par le travail est au dessus sinon
les pièces nous assemblons et nous
nous assurons la logistique ça permet de
faire le la fabrication jusqu'à
l'expédition et pour nos travailleurs ça
les implique dans leur métier au final
autour d'un simple somme y ait une
cohésion d'innovation et d'initiative
nivernaise un mode d'emploi que le grand
public et le jury du concours lépine
pourront découvrir à paris du 27 avril
au 8 mai